craving is built in what you say into
the human mind because of the different
biological pathways that course through
our genetics or is it something more
malleable that's epigenetically perhaps
imprinted by the environment Emilio the
culture even that we grow up in I would
say some of both
so certainly these urges to act drive
our very basic survival mechanisms you
know so you know it's these mechanisms
are set up to help us remember where
food is and also to remember we're
dangerous so we can avoid it and it's
interesting dopamine firing happens when
we get an unexpected reward right you
know so you can imagine you're wandering
around the savannah suddenly find a food
source your brain fires this dopamine
off it says hey remember this place so
you can come back here tomorrow and get
some more food same thing you know you
see this average of tiger and you're
like oh it's danger over here remember
this don't come back here tomorrow but
that dopamine firing doesn't happen
every time we get to that food source
because we've already learned it right
that that firing shifts from receiving
the reward you know from finding that
food to anticipating so that dopamine
firing goes to it says hey you know get
off your butt go get the food so it
motivates us to action once we've
learned the behavior and so that's
actually where the craving comes in so
there's a that's a very basic learning
mechanism yet you know I wouldn't say it
suggests well great example cigarettes
do not help our survival but we can
actually learn to Craig cigarettes in
the same way that we you know that these
mechanisms help us find food
[Music]